depuis 18 mois environ on voit en france
des hommes et des dames aussi bien
qu'ils ont sur les oreilles un casque
leur permettant d'écouter la musique
même dans les bruits de la circulation
ce sont des walkman l'invention est dû
au président d'une grande firme
japonaise d'appareils audiovisuels qui
désirait lui écouter de la musique tout
en jouant au golf
vous avez sûrement croisé au détour
d'une rue un de ses personnages bizarres
fois fait d'un drôle de casse rappelez
vous il ne manquait que les antennes
pour évoquer une autre planète
mais n'ayez pas peur ils ont simplement
un groupe man beaucoup de gens qui me
regardent avec avec un air une nouvelle
génération du xxème siècle en salle et à
la paix moi je m'en fous éperdument et
je suis bien ses principales
pour les connaisseurs le lecteur de
cassettes stéréophonie est devenu
l'indispensable signe d'appartenance à
une certaine caste image de marque ils
véhiculent et celle de l'action de la
jeunesse et du dynamisme
ils ont la sensation de pouvoir se
dégager tout ce qui est autour de soi de
pouvoir écouter la musique
s'extérioriser en soi même être bien et
il y souvent un travail d'invention qui
enchante surtout les vendeurs 1 millions
d'appareils vendus en france depuis 1o
n'y sont pris entre 800 et 1200 francs
hoffman dans le métro parce que ça
présente assez important parce que je
viens tu vois la maîtrise le métro les
gens
la musique jeux
jazz rock aussi tout à fait détendue est
vraiment important mais c'est une façon
de se couper du monde
c'est une façon j'ai coupé du monde
croie ou est lui aussi j'aime bien la
musique tu vois moi j'écoute ce que
j'aime puisque c'est que j'enregistre et
puis tu meurs une mode
oui mais une mode peut être pas sans
conséquences il ne s'agit pas d' éviter
aux autres le bruit que l'on peut faire
mais de s'éviter à soit le bruit et la
présence les autres
pour les psychiatres c'est une nouvelle
rupture plus grave que celle des
générations alors ce danseur ou walkman
fait-il un pas en arrière ou un pas en
avant